it's time for another food adventure
let's go
what's up oh my god how's it going okay
yeah you want to get some food
what are we eating
steak
yeah i would do that should we take adam
of course
hey adam
what is happening
all right andrew today we're eating
three steaks
today we are eating three different
steaks at three different price points
and we're gonna find out which one is
the most worth it at its price the most
worth it because that's what we're
calling this it's called worth it worth
it how do we want to judge these sticks
i think we should get medium rare i mean
that's the only way to eat steak right
it's not the only way but it is the best
way ten dollars for parking geez loo
hashtag not worth it which is funny
because the first steak is actually 11 i
hope this isn't a mystic oh
that was terrible if a vampire comes
along maybe i'll have to kill it with a
stick i'm so done with your puns we'll
get ready for more because it's going to
be
punishment
[Music]
my name is shirley ying and i'm the
manager of uncle john's cafe originally
the owner started it as a american diner
and a chinese owner purchased the
business so we incorporated chinese food
in it you can get pancake or yeah
unconventional with a chow mein it just
works this diner is my childhood because
that's what i would eat growing up we're
going to serve you guys uncle john's
chicken egg we start off with a cut of
new york steak it's about eight ounces
we marinate it with a little bit of soy
sauce garlic salt salt and pepper and
it's eleven dollars eleven dollars and
it's not only the steak it comes with
two eggs however you like it and it also
comes with a side and toast how can you
provide it at this price we have other
items on the menu that helps outweigh
the cost of the steak for a diner you
need the steak and eggs and it's just on
the menu because people want steak and
eggs for breakfast not just 11 steak 11
steak plus fried eggs with pancakes and
they have thai tea here and black coffee
cheers it's probably the most excited
i've ever been for a meal in my life
that is so good
whoa
yeah dog
she knew what she was doing we have to
cheers to steak how about we like elbow
touch like we just touch ports
yeah that's good look at that delicious
morsel my mom used to cook safe for me
growing up this is exactly the same
recipe she would use love you mama let's
get real here this is america on a plate
fried rice two eggs a giant-ass steak
ketchup syrup chili oil salt pepper a1
steak sauce sriracha this is seriously
one of the best meals i've ever had in
my life i can tell you right now this
wins you're not gonna find a better deal
on steak anywhere it's okay man
let's go to the next place i guess let's
go
[Applause]
wow you know that steak was really good
hello hey mom how's it going
so we ate steak and on the side was
fried rice and eggs
it was really good i'm here with andrew
and adam too
yes
[Music]
all right love you too bye ready for a
medium rare steak fact think back did
you know that you're more likely to die
from a cow
than a shark describe a cow related
death you know sometimes cows get tired
of you milking it and they just they
just revolt what's our band name how do
we feel about the three busketeers
that's a fan favorite
it'll grow on you nothing grows on me
except
hair
probably some moles
[Music]
my name is andreas roller i'm the
executive chef here at negan staff
steakhouse in downtown l.a here we have
our beautiful 28 day dry aged prime bone
in rib eye we dry it here on premises so
why do you dry it maybe not the right
term but it's a little bit like spoiling
on a very controlled level to tenderize
the meat this little fur here you know
it might look a little scary this piece
we cut all this off this is an
indication that the dry icing process
has happened correctly another thing
that happens is kind of like when you
reduce a sauce as there is less moisture
flavors get intensified so this is not
dry aging this is not right just arrived
yesterday it's still pretty moist and
this has been 28 days in the dry age
this is the real deal here you see i put
a lot of salt and you know a lot of
people when they first see this they're
like oh my god this is a lot of salt but
believe me at 28 ounces you want to make
sure your steak is well seasoned so
we're putting our steaks on what we're
looking for here is to get that
caramelized crust on the outside the
characteristic of the flavor i always
think this it's like it has a bit
nuttiness you know when you have a
cheese that is matured it's like a good
deeper thinking yes yeah
andrew stephen this is the greatest
presentation we've ever received on this
show i'm actually very confused because
this is only our second stop of the day
oh my goodness do you see that my knife
has never had an easier time going
through me cheers
[Music]
wow yeah holy moly this is how people
live
it's like a satisfying savory taffy
perfectly tender you gotta chew it for a
second and then it just dissolves into
your mouth sometimes you get things this
big you get tired of them no that
doesn't happen here i'm also going to
say that eating this steak with this big
boy knife really does a lot for the
whole experience
that was way good we have one more steak
to eat are you ready this is my burden
to bear now
this is crazy
that steak was magnificent i definitely
went into that steak situation thinking
i know what steak's gonna taste like
steak fact
steak fact the best fact we've ever had
in a drought beef prices rise
[Music]
that's it that's it in a drought the
price of everything rises
hot air
we're in beverly hills baby how could
this steak be more worth than the last
two
um
i guess like come from a
fancier cow
i am hillary the chef to cuisine at cut
beverly hills today i'm grilling two
steaks building a dry age new york strip
steak this dries for 35 days the dry age
is 48 that's actually a pretty good deal
it's a great deal the other steak is a
japanese new york strip 25 an ounce so
what separates this 25 an ounce steak
this japanese beef is from miyazaki
prefecture these cattle have been bred
for thousands of years i have a
certificate that tells me all about this
animal you trace it back 80 years so who
are we eating today i don't want to give
this a name we're about to eat the food
yeah but it's a beautiful product so we
should respect it exactly this is the
reason that cow was raised for you to
enjoy it we're going to be eating kanga
today order in a steak it gets seasoned
with our house steak sauce quite a few
ingredients and then it's grilled over
white oak and charcoal and then the
steak comes off it rests and we flash it
in our 1200 degree boiler brush it with
a little garlic butter fleur-de-celle
and geotaping so this whole process
takes about how long is it an eyeball
thing is it uh you're counting no you
feel it after you do it for so long feel
it is there a better cut of steak in the
world if there is i haven't had it yet
did you hear that
that's fresh definitely feel the breeze
off the ocean on that one it's a nice
little appetizer chef hilary wanted us
to first try her 48 dry each prime new
york strip like a hot knife through
butter cheers
very interesting that was a wonderfully
tender steak it was a nice dance let's
do your steak dance
all right stop that and now the grand
finale japanese beef from miyazaki my
nose is having almost as much fun as my
mouth is on this one let me select us
some delightful morsels to eat my heart
is racing right now okay that was the
most fun i've ever had cutting something
before
cheers
[Music]
hmm
okay
that's the one that is a completely new
thing there's fat marbled into every
single bite that you get it tastes like
pure luxury i'm like embarrassed to be
watched eating this because it's like
something so pleasurable shouldn't be
done in public do we let camera guy have
some yeah we should
[Music]
it's the first time i've seen adam
really smile before in my life
ridiculous was this worth it a thousand
percent yes so you're gonna come back
here yes i'm gonna bring my girlfriend
back here if you were to use one final
word to describe this entire experience
what would that word be
legendary seriously though candy corn
fine
which steak was the most worth it at its
price no restaurant has understood who i
am as a human being more than uncle
john's i think uncle john's is the only
one that you cannot argue that it isn't
worth it this is the hardest decision
i've ever had to make on this show and i
can't believe i'm saying this cut wins
you can't pay down your life change like
that i think i choose nick and steph
there were a lot of different things
happening in that state the steak itself
was a journey adam what's your winner
three musketeers well that was a worth
it episode
well done oh my gosh okay can we cut the
video stop and there's no rare
experience no